entertainment businesswoman juliana
rancic and her restaurant or husband
bill rancic have brought a taste of
italy to las vegas jillian sat down with
the couple to kick off the grand opening
of rpm italiano
[Music]
we are popping the bubbly we have an
exciting celebration today rpm italian
has officially opened here at caesar's
palace and i am joined by the brains and
the beauty behind it i am here with
giuliana and bill rancic before we do
anything we gotta have a cheers you guys
congratulations thank you i'm so happy
to have you out here in las vegas your
first location juliana i'll start with
you how special is it to be a part of
the las vegas community now
we are so excited this has been years in
the making by the way we have been
trying to find the perfect location for
an rpm italian here in las vegas and
being here at the forum shops is a dream
come true i mean i've been coming to the
form shops for so many years with my own
parents and then to be able to walk
through the shops with bill and my son
our son duke
with our son duke has been such a joy so
we're very very excited about being in
las vegas i think we got to get to the
food what do you guys say let's do it
well we are lucky because we are getting
a one of a kind dish here in las vegas
bill tell me about this i'm already
drooling this is pretty special this is
the garganzola crusted wagyu beef
and we sourced the beef from the beeman
ranch in harwood texas which is a family
ranch we're very proud of all the
way
we're very proud of how we source all
the ingredients here and we try to get
as many family farms as we can and
really try to understand where the food
comes from so i'm gonna serve you right
now wow i'm getting served to the las
vegas menu
oh my gosh and also exclusive i have to
mention is your prosecco right yes so we
have our prosecco here today as well
which is the giuliana prosecco and
it's really nice if you've got to try it
it has like a knife
yes yes
it's not too sweet which i love you know
sometimes bubbly can be a little sweet
this is not it's just sweet enough but
not overly sweet it's nice and dry and
just a really wonderful thing
i'm going to cut this up for you okay
i'm getting it and i'm going to keep
your feet right here you go here you go
i want you to be drinking champagne in
prison while you're reading that i'm
going to interview julianna so joanna
can you tell us a little bit about the
mama de panties bucatini pomodoro yeah
so this is based on my mom's famous now
famous recipe mama japanese book of team
pomodoro i grew up eating this it's
amazing i was actually born in naples
italy
we came to this country when i was a
little girl and i grew up on this dish
and i'll tell you it took over 30 tries
for the team to perfect
this dish with my mom in the kitchen
helping perfect it
and
in the 10 years that we have been open
at rpm that rpm italian's been in
chicago
nothing has ever beat this on any given
night this is the best-selling dish what
sign are you i'm a pisces what are you
doing i'm a leo okay what's your sign
i'm a taurus today is my birthday
so thank you it is happy birthday bill
you're spending your birthday with us
here in las vegas
we are honored
oh my gosh well happy birthday bill
congratulations juliana and bill this is
amazing i know i'm going to spend a lot
of my weekend nights here celebrating
and i just i need a straw to go with
that prosecco and i'm good to go
thank you congratulations be sure to
come visit rpm italian right here in the
forum shop at caesars cheers